people try to steal from behind in the
front court on a fast break
you do it in the backcourt on the
inbound or off of a change of
possessions
what were the sidelines what were your
teammates what were your coaches telling
you like I'm sure they didn't approve
I mean it just happened actually when I
was around like seven grades eighth
grade but I got in trouble for it for a
while you know people tell me you would
not make any team going that my college
plus was like if you do that I'm subbing
you out so I'm like and in the NBA coach
won't be Rainey really never said
nothing I think he didn't know I was
doing that first I think he was lost too
I think he was just looking up so he
couldn't really say nothing at the time
but when I did do it I was ready the
ball was stolen so he he liked it he
never told me nothing never told nothing
about it I'm trying to figure out and
this is what Alvarado does
all right well the whole world knows
sometimes I took it to the rest of my